説明できないかもしれません
こちらの 難しいんですよ
で 難しさでも ただ覚えているならば簡単なんですけどね
まあ次にあるのはこの五十三ページにあるこの
えーと サンパヨガ・ナヤなんですね
相応の仕方 で そういうのを勉強するためには覚えておかないと
心はどんなどんな心ですかと
ああだこうだとか 覚えてないと進まないんです
ですから まあなんか簡単に言うしかないんですけど
まあ少々簡単にいきましょう
で あのサンガハ・ガーターティ・モノガテ
サッチャ・サッバッタ・ユッジャンティ・ヤタ・ヨガ・パキンナカ・シュッダサ・クサレーセ・クサレースヴェーワ・ソーバネー・スワ・ス・エーワ・ソーバナ
で で あの心所が五十二ありまして
どんな心にどんな心所がありますかという説明なんですね
できるだけ私はいくらかのことは心所の説明ではもうずっと言ったんです
理解しやすく で ここでまあわざわざと明確に言ってるだけ
心が八十九あります あるいは百二十一種類あるんですね
で と言うんだけど 結局心という性質はたった一つなんですね
そこで私が言った例えは水の例えなんですね
水でいえばたった一種類しかないんです
そこで我々には世の中でいろんな水の種類が出てくるんですね
実際には それは水に溶けているものによって
水がいろいろ名前が 川の水や海の水とか
そういう風になるんですね
川の水と海の水はどう違いますかというと
必ずしもその水の中に溶いている成分によってその差が生まれてくるんです
その差が消えちゃったら
この なんという魚でしたっけ？川に上ってくるの
え 鮭が出てこなくなっちゃう
来れなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから  まあ鮭にとっては
その まあ味覚でしょうね
もしかすると ものすごく鋭く
それは道のように感じるんですね
この水の性質は ですから
あっちこっちを泳いどいで
まあ繁殖の時期になってくると
その海の方に行って 海に水が入ったばっかりだから
その道が見えてくるんです
そこで目に頼ることなく
この水の匂いに頼ってずっと上まで登っていくんです
ですから 水の成分が違う
それで水がいろいろ種類があります
ですから 心の二十 百二十一あるということは
百二十一方法で心所の組み合わせがあるということなんです
それを簡単に勉強したければ
一つの方法は一つの心をとって
その心にどれぐらい心所が入っているかということを覚えておけば
そういうリストはあるんです
この本にもあると思います
この付録の表一で六十八ページ
六十八ページ 六十九ページに二つにまたがってますが
まあそこにも何のことなく全部別々に書いてあるんです
そのリスト使えば この難しい勉強は全部それで終わっちゃうんです
アビダンマテキストでは二つの立場で説明するんですよ
例えば心所を取って どんな心にこの心所が生まれるかという方法と
心を持ってその心にどんな心所が入りますかという両面から見てるだけ
他のリスト何ですかね
八十九ページ あ そちらになってくるとまた少々違いますけどね
大体心所の数ですか それはまあそちらでもちゃんと入ってます
ですから そこら辺まあ難しくなりますから
まあなんとか簡単に説明します
で 一番初めに出てくるのはアンニャサマーナチェータシカサンパヨーガナ
初めに出てくるのはこの共一際心所
それは七つありますね
共一際心所は七つあります
それはパッサ ヴェーダナ
サンニャ チェータナ エーカガタ
ジーティ インドリヤ マナシカラという七つなんですね
今の状態 状態では全部覚えておかないと
で 説明しにくいんだけど
まあサッバチッタサーダラナチェータシカ
共一際心所 私も日本語で覚えてないんだから
なかなか言いにくいんですけどね
それはパッサ ヴェーダナ
サンニャ チェータナ エーカガタ
ジーティ インドリヤ マナシカラ
パーリ語で言うならば
それは共一際心所だから
百二十一のすべての心にあるものです
その説明はまあ嫌になるほど説明しました
で 私の説明で 現代的な説明で言うならば
心という現象が生まれるために
この七つの働きが必要ですよということなんですね
パッサというのはcontact
触れること いわゆるこちらにいる私と外界
何かに触れなくちゃいけない
私と言ったっても それは言葉だけのことですけど
まあこちらに体でもいいし
心でもいいし そこと外の世界は触れる
で こちらと人間っていうのはゲンニービーセッシンイーに六つに分けてるんですね
わかりやすく で ゲンニービーセッシンイーに六つのものは触れる
色声香味触法というものは
ですから 最初からも仏教ではこの心は別に別々な働きとして扱っているんですね
いわゆる六根として 目があって
耳があって 鼻があって
舌があって 体の感覚があって
そこで五つと それから心があると
意があるんだと 目で見える
鼻で香りを嗅ぐ 耳で音を聞く
舌で味を味わう 体で感覚
触れる 感覚を受ける 意で考える
そういう六つの窓口があります
その六つの窓口に我々は私と言うんですね
ですから 最初から眼耳鼻舌意に分けたところでも
仏教は智慧の世界にいるんですよ
目は私ですか？と言えば目は私ではありませんし
耳は私ですか？というと耳は私ではありませんし
他のものを私ですか？舌は私ですか？と言って
舌は私ではありません
例えば舌抜いても あ それは舌ですよと
私はこっちだよと言うんですね
目が見えなくなっても
それは目だよと 私はこっちいるよと
私というのは妄想概念だからすぐ逃げる
六つに分けてみたら どっちが私ですか？と言ったら
どっちも言えない 納得いかないんですね
なぜならば一つ取ったらこれは私ですと言ったら
他のものを捨てなさいと言ったら
そうも捨てられないでしょうに
真我に戻りたければね
だからそれは分析したのはこの我々のためというより
お釈迦様はこのインド文化の人々のために理解できるように
そういう分析をしてあげたんです
インドの文化はそのまま全部壊しちゃったというか
壊しちゃったんですね
で 全部まとめて論じるんですね
インドの思想では 日本も同じなんですね
まとめたところに実体があると思っちゃうんですね
それ生け花なんか見るとね
そこにすごい哲学があるんだと
生き方があるんだと すっごく真剣に修行したりして
で もう別に綺麗でもなんでもない
どうでもいいくだらないものをまとめて
それ生け花というものを作って
まとめたところで何か形が出てくるんですね
そこに事実があるんだと
ないのは当たり前なんですけど
で そういうふうなことはまあインドでもよくやってたんです
ヨーロッパ人は最近ですけどね
ヨーロッパ人はそんなに比べるぐらいまだ発展してないんだけど
分析するということになって
唯物論に陥ってしまって
神も死んでしまって もう何もなくなっちゃって
もうどうでもいいない
もうただ獣みたいな状態になってしまったんですね
精神的には 最初から幻覚の中に生きてたんだから
道徳的にそれほど打ちいたことはないんですね
東洋の場合は まとめて考えるんだから
どっちでも嘘なんですけどね
ですから 仏教はもうまず分析から始めたんです
ヨーロッパはもう最近でしたけど
もう遠い昔 もうまず分析からと
なぜならば まとめて考えることはすでにあったんだから
花を生けたところで事実があるぞと思ったってもね
何が事実かと でまあ 例えば日本の文化から言えば
この茶道もね お茶の方も同じことなんですね
別々に分析してみてください
もう何のこともないんです
面白くも何ともないと思いますよ
でもまとめたところで
そこに美が生まれてくるんですね
人が集めて すごく静かにすごく座って
そこで時間をかけてゆっくりとお茶を淹れる
一つ一つもうきめ細かく
もう仕切りがあって まあお茶の粉を取る
あれももう決まってあって
それもうそこで何か美というものは生まれてきて
そこでみんな喜びを感じるんですね
喜びを感じるんだから
そこに事実というものがあるんだと
でも掴めません どちらかと具体的じゃないんですね
ですから それまた東洋の神秘やと言いながら
またさらにその上考えたりする
それはそう置いといて
で この私というものがあるんだと
という立場から哲学をインドの哲学をね
始めたんだから お釈迦さん
何のことなく人間っていうのは原理比照心を持つでしょう
それをあんた反対しますか？と言ったら
反対はしませんと 原理比照心
意があるんだと じゃあそれ以外に何かあるんですか？と言えば
それはそれだけです じゃあ聞きますけど
あなたの目はあなたですか？と
向こうも正直だから いえ
目は私とは言いませんと
では逆に目はどうですかね
目自体見たらそれは永遠のものですか？と
私腹ですか？と いえ 目は永遠じゃない
目は私腹じゃない 目自体見たら
苦しみだから じゃあ私腹でもない
永遠でもないものは私だ
私の我だと思いますか？と
思うのは正しいか いえ
そうは思いませんと じゃあそれだったら目を置いておきましょうと
無我であって無常であると
で 耳に行ったり それで全部六つにいく
それで意の場合は それよく誤解しやすいんですね
大体人間っていうのは考えるんだから私がいると思ってるんですね
私は考えている だから私がいるというのはごく普通の
どんな愚か者でも知ってることなんです
それには別に頭が進んでなくても
もう犬さえ知ってるんです
私はいるんだと それなりに考えてるんだから
で そこで仏教で言うんで
あなたの意はどうですかと
でも考えるんだけど 無茶苦茶ですよね
瞬間瞬間変わっていくんだから
じゃあ意そのものが私腹ですかね
考えることは私腹ですかね
それすごい苦しみでしょうに
いろんなこと 嫌なものもほとんど嫌なものばっかり考えたりしている
ずっと嫌なものを考えている人は
すぐ何か環境変わったらすぐ違うことを考えるしまっちゃうし
大喜びで幸福を感じている人は
ちょっとした出来事があったらものすごく
例えばどこかへ行ってお祭りなんかやって
もうわいわい騒いでる瞬間で
自分の携帯電話鳴っても
もう実はあなたの子供がもう死んだ
事故で死んだよと言ってみてください
あ そう じゃあ今遊んでるんだから後で来ますよという状態になりますかね
それはならないんですからね
瞬間でも変わりますよ
すごい喜んでいるんだから
その人に泣くには時間かかりますよと
時間かかりますかね？ものすごく笑っている人は瞬間にもう泣くということはできません
ですから この意そのものはそれほど当てにならない
目だったらいくらか当てになりますけどね
お釈迦様それをからかってこう言うんです
人間が魂だ 私だ 我だと
体の方が我だと言ったっても我慢できますと
そう言うんです 私の体は私の魂やと言うならば我慢できますと
でも私の思考 私の心 私の精神が我だというのはもう全く我慢できないんだと
そういうような言葉があるんです
お釈迦様の言うはこの
体というのは結構持つんだと 1
年 2年 3年 4年 10年とか
たまに人がいるんだと
わずかな病気もくしゃみもしないで 80
年とか90年まで生きてる人もいるんだと
だから体が魂だと言うならば我慢できますよと
いくらか 心が魂って言うんだから
この人々 心っていうのはわずか瞬間でも同じものではないんだと
だから馬鹿がいいところだということは言ってるんですよ
そういうことで 眼耳鼻舌身意という六つがあって
それ一つ一つ我々は我だとまとめたところで我だと思う
ですから この仏教理解者はもう生け花でもすごくいい例なんですよ
植えたところで美しいんです
それが問題はないんです
植えただけでダメなんですよ
それはそれなりの場所に置いとかなくちゃいけない
宇宙の空間に置いとかなくちゃいけないんです
だから花を作るということは
何て言いますか 小宇宙というんですか
そういう小さな宇宙を作ることなんですよ
その小さな宇宙を作って
それはどこかに入れておく
そこで大きな宇宙の中の位置づけなんですね
そこで初めてその美しく光り輝くんですね
その作品が きれいな生け花といって
どこに置いたってもきれいっていうわけじゃないんです
台所の洗面 台所の何て言いますか
あれは洗面ですか？何て言いますか
日本語で 流し台に置いたってもきれいじゃないんですよ
迷惑ですよ その時は 誰かそれ片付けてくれませんかと
言いたくなるんじゃないんですか？すぐそう言うんですよ
これこっち置いたらダメですよと
それはもう迷惑ということを感じているんだからなんです
それはそれにふさわしい場所に置いたところで美が生まれてくる
ですから このマイクロコスモですか
マクロコスモに持っていかなくちゃいけない
それで位置づけをちゃんと作らなくちゃいけない
そこで美という実体が生まれて
で そこでこのみんなこの何十年も修行したってそれだけのことなんですけど
それを理解すればすぐできますよ
でお茶の場合も同じく
ちょっと違いますけど
お茶の場合はね お茶の場合は逆の論理でね
マクロコスモからいかにマイクロコスモというものを作るかということで
それまた美しいと で 両方のやり方ですけど
で 日本の美っていうのはすごい幅広いんだからね
侘びも寂びもあって とてつもない派手もありますから
もう世界で誰よりも派手なこと
着物とか見るとね あれほど派手な服なんかこの世の中で誰も着ないと思いますよ
あれほど派手な もうこういうエリザベス女王も着ませんと思いますよ
あれは高いだけでね いろんな宝石いっぱい散りばめてる服を着たりとか
それもほんの瞬間だけですけどね
儀式儀礼に参加する時だけ
国会の儀式と その時はもうすごい服を着て現れますけどね
でもあれは価値ではもう高いだけで
派手といえば着物の方が派手なんです
エリザベス女王が国会に出る時と
日本の人がもし着物を着ていたら
もうこちらの方が派手と思いますけど
でもそれも一つの美の世界なんですね
ですから このみんな嘘を言ってますけど
日本は派手なことを嫌いだとね
それは嘘です 嘘をつくことも一つの美ですからね
朝から晩まで嘘に固まってる人生
まあまあ それも一つの文化
文化だからね しょうがないんだけど
で あの まあそれぞれいろいろありますけど
我々のこの仏教のね 意味を理解するためにはね
それはちゃんと使いますね
例えばこの生け花の美がどこに生まれますかと
美がそのマイクロコスモがマクロコスモの世界にある小宇宙が小宇宙を大きな宇宙の中に
このちゃんとしたところに置いたところに美が生まれてくるんだと
ですから美は実体ですかと言えば
それは実体ではないんだと
それは幻だと それはもう作品ですね
美っていうのはできたもの
だから仏教でそれには簡単にサンカーラという言葉を使うんですね
サンカーラっていうのはできたもの
組み立てたもの 実体ではないと
全てはサンカーラであると
心もサンカーラなんです
物質もサンカーラなんです
サンカーラには残念ながらね
日本語の言葉がないし
英語の言葉もないし まあ漢字では行と書きますけどね
行くという漢字 なんで行と書いたんですか
さっぱりわかりません
どこかに行くわけではないんだけど
まあそれでも何かこの停止している言葉じゃないんだからね
悪いわけじゃないんだけど
行ですからね 働きというような意味ですからね
ですから 見という働きが生まれる
そこで見る人々は何のことなく楽しくなっちゃうんですね
そこで働きが生まれてるんだから
で この我はそういうもので
眼耳鼻舌身意という六つ
六つが まあ適当に組み合わせたところで
私というサンカーラが生まれてくるんです
それは全然分析も何もできない
単なる幻覚 適当にないとダメなんです
目はあっちこっちやったりとかね
鼻はどこかにあったりとかね
自分の鼻が渋谷にあって
目はもう新宿にあってとかね
それで私がいるわけじゃなくて
それはやっぱりそれなりに揃ってないと
意識は別なところにあったりとかね
それはよくありますけど
それはまあ それで この
まあそれは我であって
それでアビダンマ始まる時でも
やっぱりもう眼耳鼻舌身意というこの六つのカテゴリーっていうのはいつでも出てきて
それはすごく大事なポイントなんです
で その大体 例えばルーパ
ヴェーダナ サンニャ サンカーラ
五蘊の分析がありますね
色蘊 受蘊 サンニャ サンニャ
色ですか 受蘊とルーパ
ヴェーダナ サンニャ サンカーラ
行蘊と識蘊 五蘊に分けてるんですね
ほとんど誰も理解しないんですけどね
五蘊って何ですかと 理解しないんだけど
やっぱりそれもこのインド哲学背景から生まれてきている分析なんです
それを分析しただけで仏教はもう我を壊しちゃったんです
自我を殺しちゃったんです
それだけで悟れるんです
だからお釈迦様の説法を聞いた頃
お釈迦様はただ 例えば五蘊の
五人の比丘たちをどのように悟ったかというと
この五蘊のことを説明してね
体は色 物質があって 受
感覚があって 想 いろいろこの頭の働きがあったりとか
それから行 もうその場合はもう何かやらなければいけないという
このもう機動力みたいな
みたいな このポテンシャルみたいなエネルギーなんで
そこがあって それから色って心というものがあったりして
六つに五つに分けて 体ってそれぐらいでしょう
それぐらい じゃあ一つ一つ見てくださいと
見るとそれは色蘊は変化する
変化するものは無常である
無常であるものは苦か楽かといえば苦ですと
どちらかにしなくちゃいけないのです
苦たるものは無常たるものは私だがだ
実体だと思えますか？と思いません
じゃあ色に対する執着を捨てなさい
そういう説法で もうみんな完全に悟ったんですよ
だからこの自我捨てると
また何か取らないとという差で
ですから もうなかなかこの
後でヒンドゥー教が発展してるの後なんです
仏教の概念を借りて この梵我一如の説明はものすごく後で説明し直しちゃったんですね
そこでどっちも負けない状態になってしまったんです
いつでもパラレルでもずっと延々と言っちゃいますけど
で ヒンドゥー教の人は仏教を批判しないし
仏教の人はいくら批判したっても批判されたことにならない状態になってしまったんです
で 仏教の人々にもなかなかヒンドゥー教の弱いところをつかめるほどの知識人は現れなかったんです
この後で この八世紀 九世紀あたりって
それで仏教は負けてしまったんですけど
もう大乗仏教が発展してたんだからね
当然インドから仏教は消えてしまったんですけど
初期仏教の状態だったならば
もうなんとか生き延びるんだけどね
ですから わずかにいまだに昔から仏教を信仰した人々はわずかですけど
いることはいるんです
大乗仏教の人は一人いませんだけど
遠い昔からお釈迦様の時代から
この今 バルワ系の人々はもうほとんど仏教を知っているわけじゃないんだけど
ヒンドゥー教じゃないんですね
で すごく自慢してるんですね
我々はまあお釈迦様時代から仏教徒でいたんだと
ですから  それから仏教学者として出てくる教授になるインド人はほとんどバルワですね
それも当たり前で バルワっていうのはヴィハーラという言葉から出てくる言葉です
ヴィハーラってお寺 仏教のお寺という
ですから この自我をそういう風に捨てることで
まあまあ それはまあ経典の話でアビダンマの話ではないんだけど
とにかく じゃあまた話に戻ります
アビダンマ世界に 眼耳鼻舌身意があって
そこに何か触れなくちゃ
ぶつからなくちゃ色が生れません
だから触れるものは色受想行識という六つにする
それはあくまでも言葉
名前ですから 眼耳鼻舌身意に何かエネルギーは六種類のエネルギーが触れると
その触れることで認識が生まれるんだから
もう心が生まれるためには触
パッサは確実に必要なんです
それから次に受 触れたことを感じると
サンニャ 触れたことを何ものかと区別を見なくちゃいけない
それからチェータナ 意志が生まれる
エーカーガタ その触れたことに集中する
触れたものに で そこでジーヴィティンドリヤという命根ですか
そういう心性も入ってあって
何のために入ってるかわかりませんだけど
マヌシカーラ で そこに心の働きが生まれるという
というまあちょっと難しいんですけど
またまあやったことだから
また繰り返して言いません
だからマヌシカーラ全部説明しましたからね
ですから その七つは確実にどんな心にもあります
ですから 共心所 共一切心所は七つであって
どこにもあります ですから
どんな心にも命根というものがありますよと
命根というのは心として
命として扱っていることなんですね
心もまあある一定の命みたいなもので
マヌシカーラっていうのは
才ですかね 日本語の言葉は
何でしたっけ 才 この何かの働きというか
この ちょっとしたこの働きなんですね
心の働き いわゆる見よう聞こうというような働きなんです
見よう聞こう 味わおう
嗅ごうという働きなんですね
味見を見るとき よく皆様やってるんでしょうね
もう舌を平らにして よく触れるようにして
その物体をね 舌に 音まで出したりしてね
その時のマナシカーラっていうもの働くんです
で 匂い嗅いでみる時でも同じことで
普通は匂いはわからないと
これどんな匂いかといって
で そこでそこに集中する
そこでこの味覚のさらにさらにそこにいるとかなんとかしながら
かぶりをね 嗅いで区別してみようとかね
それまあそこら辺が進んでる人々には
例えばこのテレビで見たんだけどね
いろんなミネラルウォーターを持ってきて
目を隠して もうある人は飲んで
これ何々水だというし
また匂いでどんなものかと区別できる人ね
それはまあ育てられますね
この感覚っていうのは
それマナシカーラなんですね
マナシカーラ育てれば
そこら辺にも幅広く認識が生まれてきます
あるいは過去生で犬だった人には
今生でももう匂いで区別できると
牛は味覚は鋭いというんだからね
まあ言うんですけど どうかわかりませんだけど
まあ次に出てくる心所
じゃあ共有する心所はまあそれぐらいにして
次に出てくるアニャ・サマーナ
パキッナカ・チェータシカ
つありますね ヴィタッカ
ヴィターラ アジムッカ
ヴィリヤ ピーティ チャンダカ
あの心所の方が開けておいた方が分かりやすいかもしれません
四十七ページにあのパキッナカ・チェータシカって六つ書いてますね
ヴィタッカ ヴィターラ
アジムッカ ヴィリヤ ピーティ
チャンド で 本当はそれはそのまま覚えておいた方が勉強しやすいんですけどね
ヴィタッカ ヴィターラ
アジムッカ ヴィリヤ ピーティ
チャンドと その三つにパキッナカというのは
それは善心にも不善心にも出世間心にもどちらでも生まれるんですね
リストは四十七ページであります
今日の勉強は五十三ページの勉強
[背景音楽]で そこで善心にこの
この雑心生生まれると
その心生も善心生になる
不善心に生まれると そのパキンナカ心生が不善心生になる
それは差なんですね ヴィタッカっていうのは考えることで
ヴィチャーラっていうのは
あの 同じ考えることなんですけど
この粗っぽいか細かいかっていうことなんですね
いわゆる分かりやすく
強引に何か考えるとヴィタッカで
まあ強引でなくても まあ自然に考え方が流れてるとヴィッチャーラの方があるんです
これは日本  しん？じん
し え？ し  し 一番目は？ じん
じんとしという  これ漢字
いや 悪くもなく で まあ単なる絵を入れてるような感じ
そういう絵で表してます
ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラの差は
ブッダごっつ 大長老もなかなか明確に説明できてないんです
そういう分苦労しているんです
うーん 瞑想体験があると
体験っていうのは瞑想経験があると
あのな いくらかわかると思いますね
例えばこの 自分でこの積極的に物事を確認する
大体最初はそうなっちゃうんですね
積極的に膨らみと縮みと痛みと妄想とかなんとかなんとか
積極的に確認しなくちゃいけない
それを積極的に確認していって
いっていって どんどんどんどん慣れてくると
別に積極的でなくても確認は流れていくと
で この積極的に確認する場合は
ヴィタッカというじんがかなり働いています
そこで まあ別に積極的でなくても
もう確認状態に乗ってしまったら
もう確認は流れていく
その場合は し がまあ起動
機能しているんです いわゆるじんがなくてもできるようになったんですね
だからそんな差ですよと
ヴィタッカとヴィチャーラが
やることは同じ 考えることなんですけど
ということは 誰でもかなりヴィタッカ使うんです
ヴィタッカというのは
この言葉の定義を見ると
もうロジック タルカですから
タッカですから このアーギュメントですか
まあ論理みたいな意味なんですけどね
いわゆる頭の中で我々結構言葉を使って考えてるでしょうに
言葉使って考えなきゃ考えられないんですね
ずっと頭の中で言葉から言葉
言葉から言葉へと そういうのはすごいヴィタッカの働きなんです
ですから あまり大胆なことを考えられないんです
そこでこのすごいことを発見する考える人々の頭の中で
この言葉のカラクリないんです
ただボケーっとしてるんです
バカみたいに 言葉いらないんです
そこで もう でも考えているんです
その人はすっごい早いし
無駄がないし いわゆる体験
通訳しなくちゃいけないでしょ
自分使ってる言語に 通訳するともう
ほとんど意味が消えてるんだから
人が驚いたと あ 驚いたという言葉を入れると驚いたって言葉でもうあの意味がないんですよ
ですから 言葉で考える人々の方がそれほど鋭くないんです
言葉なしに物事を見て考えること人はすごい鋭くて
もう人間 他の人間にはもう何て言いますか
もう追うことはできないほど早いんです
で 瞑想からこのヴィタッカのエネルギーは控えることできるんです
ヴィパッサナーでももうかなり経験を積み重ねていると
この積極的に強引にサティを入れなくても
サッとサティの状態に戻るっていうことは体験できますからね
そうするともう流れていくんですね
瞑想自体が簡単に それで
智慧ある人はそれ進みますけどね
まあもともと智慧がない人は
まあそれでまたもう眠気が
この心性が強直 なんていうの
育てないと 育てませんだからもうダメになっちゃいますけどね
そこですぐ次のステップに自分を育てると
もうすぐ進みますけどね
そうじゃなくて ああ まあよくできるようになったんだとか何とかとか思った瞬間で不善心生もう生まれてるんだから
じゃあ初めまたやり直しっていう状態になるんです
ですから この後ろ見るんですね
いつでもみんな過去を見る
よくできるようになった
それは過去の考え方なの
過去を見るなと 前を見ていかなくちゃいけないんだから
ですから大体このヴィタッカからちょっと成長して
ヴィチャーラのレベルでやっていて